[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv 78 tout de suite les
titres de ce mardi 17 octobre un nouveau
maire pour montigny le bretonneux
jean-luc ourgaud a été élu hier soir
lors du conseil municipal de la ville
jusqu'à présent au 2ème adjoint il
succède à michel laugier en poste depuis
2004 est désormais sénateur reportage
dans ce journal
après quelques mois de travaux elle lève
le rideau l'enseigne culturel le furet
du nord ouvrira au public demain à
skywest lancement au coeur du projet de
revitalisation du centre commercial
saint quentinois axée sur le loisir nous
serons sur place dans un instant et puis
c'est votre rendez vous hebdomadaire
dans le 7-8 journal le portrait de la
rédaction ce soir nous faisons la
connaissance est alexandra bonetti à 25
ans elle est l'une des plus grande
golfeuse française de sa génération
mais avant de développer ces titres le
prochain tour de france sera de passage
dans les yvelines le tracé de la 105e
grande boucle a été dévoilée aujourd'hui
est la compétition se déroulera du 7 au
29 juillet 2018 et dernière étape au
départ de houille le département qui
accueille donc de nouveau l'ultime étape
cinq ans après versailles
au programme 115 km pour rejoindre le
grand final des champs elysées à paris
il continue de faire pression sur le
gouvernement cinq présidents des
départements d'ile-de-france sont réunis
ce soir pour une réunion publique à
versailles c'est au palais des congrès
autour de l'avenir de la métropole du
grand paris c'est en présence de gérard
larcher président du sénat bonsoir
nicolas kirillovitch vous êtes sur place
les départements continuent donc de
réclamer une métropole élargi aux
frontières de la région c'est bien
l'objet de cette réunion ce soir bonsoir
grégory en effet comme il ya deux
semaines lors d'une conférence de presse
organisée cette fois ci à paris les
présidents des départements demande
toujours que le périmètre de cette
fameuse métropole du grand paris soit
élargie aux périmètres de
la région car pour le moment cette
métropole créée le 1er janvier 2016 je
vous le rappelle se limite à la ville de
paris et aux départements de la petite
couronne
ce qui donne donc le sentiment à la
grande couronne d'être un territoire
exclus du projet urbain d'être
finalement un territoire de seconde zone
et si les départements multiplie en ce
moment les actions c'est parce que les
informations qui arrivent à leurs
oreilles ne sont pas favorables à leur
propos selon des informations récentes
parues dans la presse le gouvernement et
emmanuel macron qui s'implique
directement dans ce dans ce projet
s'arrêterait plutôt sur un périmètre
identique
rien ne changerait mise à part la
suppression des départements de la
petite couronne 92 93 94 petite couronne
donc mais aussi certains territoires
éventuelle de la grande couronne que
donc le gouvernement irait et piocher
par exemple l'aéroport
roissy-charles-de-gaulle où le plateau
paris saclay à cheval sur l'essonne et
sur les yvelines et ça c'est le scénario
catastrophe pour les présidents des
départements franciliens
et justement nicolas si cette option
était retenue auraient-elles des des
conséquences sur le projet de fusion
entre les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine
et oui les gorille c'est l'autre grand
enjeu de cette réunion publique
si les annonces du gouvernement se
confirme début novembre lors d'une
conférence prévue sur sur le grand paris
alors le projet tout simplement le
projet yvelines hauts-de-seine le projet
de fusion sera impossible puisque la
frontière de la métropole du grand paris
qui sépara alors les deux départements
sera un obstacle infranchissable
administratif pour leurs projets merci
nicolas et merci également à mélanie
poquet pour les moyens techniques
politiques plus local maintenant c'est
désormais officiel jean luc ourgaud et
le nouveau maire de montigny le
bretonneux
l'ancien adjoint remplace michel laugier
qui a été élu sénateur fin septembre le
scrutin s'est déroulé hier lors d'un
conseil municipal extraordinaire
l'émotion était palpable comme en
témoigne ce sujet de nicolas quere
lovitz
ils ont travaillé plus de vingt ans
ensemble au sein de cette assemblée
l'un quitte son poste l'autre le
découvre dans un moment très solennel
jean le court go a été élu largement
nouveau maire de montigny le bretonneux
ce lundi 16 octobre à 67 ans avec 30 de
bulletins pour sur 37 le nouvel élu
souhaite se placer dans l'action de son
prédécesseur
moi je m'inscris complètement dans les
pas de michel laugier encore une fois
comment pourrait-il en être différemment
puisque jusqu'à présent tous les
collègues de la liste ont voté pour le
programme qui a été le nôtre
donc oui c'est une continuité et pas du
tout une rupture
devenu sénateur fin septembre michel
auger qui donc un siège qu'il a occupé
pendant 13 ans ce conseil municipal
était aussi l'occasion pour les élus de
lui rendre un dernier hommage
je te les choses sont faites
quel nouveau maire montigny le
bretonneux à la tête de l'équipe que
j'ai eu l'honneur le plaisir de conduire
de sélectionner dont je leur souhaite
beaucoup de succès et je serai toujours
là avec un deck bienveillant
le nouvel organigramme municipal n'est
modifié qu'à la marge suzanne blanc
conserve ainsi son poste de première
adjointe en charge de la vie scolaire
yannick le dorze intègre lui l'exécutif
et devient responsable de la
communication une continuité qui ne
devrait pas bouleverser les relations
parfois tendues avec l'opposition
je pense qu'on a intérêt à continuer à
se battre sans relâche pour faire valoir
nos propositions allaient faire entendre
à les faire accepter parfois comme ça
parfois été le cas avec michel laugier
j'espère que ce sera le cas aussi là
avec avec jean-luc ourgaud après on a
quelques désaccords quand même sur
est-ce que montigny aujourd'hui est une
ville exemplaire en matière d'écologie
en matière de solidarité après la mairie
de montigny le bretonneux une nouvelle
élection aura lieu jeudi prochain au
sein du conseil d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pour élire le
successeur de michel logis à la
présidence de la collectivité à poste
qui devrait revenir au maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous à rambouillet et
siège désormais parmi les non inscrits
le président du parti chrétien démocrate
jean frédéric poisson quitte la majorité
de droite au conseil municipal une
rupture pour l'ancien maire de la ville
qui
faisait partie du groupe depuis 1995
raison avancée l'élu accuse le maire
adjoint dudit agile schmitt de ne pas
avoir respecté sa parole ce dernier est
devenu en juin le suppléant de la
députée lrm de la 10e circonscription
des yvelines aurore bergé qui a remporté
la circonscription face justement aux
parlementaires sortant jean frédéric
poisson retour à saint quentin en
yvelines les travaux ont débuté depuis
février ceux du pont et de l'avenue
schuller qui relie maurepas à la gare de
la verrière le chantier a pour but de
doubler les voies du pont et de créer
donc une un corridor pour les bus le
point sur les travaux avec camille
lambert et et mélanie potesses l'asphalt
vient tout juste d'être posée côté gare
de la verrière la route réservée au tcsp
transport collectif en site propre est
quasiment terminé la partie asphaltée
qu'à la plus brillante c'est réservé aux
piétons
c'est non glissant à moi parce que c'est
brillance existants la partie plus large
je vais être séparé en deux cd voies
cyclables pour la et puis la partie
entre les bordures en granit engrais
exactement sera réservé à terme
uniquement au tcsp la déviation actuelle
deviendra pérenne pour les véhicules
particuliers
du côté de maurepas le doublement du
pont schuller a pris du retard
un prolongement d'environ deux mois et
demi de travaux est envisagé lors des
explorations qui ont été faites
initialement avant le début des travaux
au niveau des culées des bombes n'ont
pas pu être décelée sur ces deux culées
de part et d'autre de la nationale
des pieux qui avait été installé il y à
quelques dizaines d'années en prévision
certainement déjà du doublement de ce
pont et il a fallu donc ré envisager la
une construction différentes et de
prévoir des micropieux un retard et un
surcoût près de 500000 euros de plus
pour cette partie des travaux
le budget initial était de près de 9
millions d'euros dont plus de six
millions de subventions de l'état de la
région et du département
l'ouverture au public se fera demain
l'enseigne culturel le furet du nord
débarqua à skywest après plusieurs mois
de travaux c'est au coeur du projet de
revitalisation du centre commercial de
30 mille mètres carrés bonsoir amical et
demi d'euros vous êtes en direct depuis
le centre commercial
une arrivée qui témoigne de la stratégie
de skywest tourner désormais vers les
loisirs et la culture
grégory vous le disiez le centre
commercial sqy ouest qui est basé ici à
monti le bretonneux est en train de
trouver une nouvelle impulsion pour nous
expliquer cette nouvelle dynamique je
suis avec le directeur du centre
mohammed madounari l'arrivée des furet
du nord
ici à montils botola skywest martèle le
début d'une nouvelle ère pour le centre
commercial
oui bonjour michael est alors
effectivement nous avons plaisir de
relancer le centre commercial sqy ouest
et ce renouveau est lancée avec cette
première pierre à l'édifice l'ouverture
de furet du nord qui arrivera qui
demandent donc du coup demain matin à 10
heures donc donc forcément c'est une
nouvelle ère qui s'annonce pour mon team
retenue et pur style ouest alors c'est
l'aboutissement d'un travail de
plusieurs années d'un projet qu'on a
voulu tourner sur la culture le sport et
le loisir
un projet qui est venu compléter une
offre déjà existante sur espace 50 ans
qui d'ailleurs petite parenthèse fêtera
ses 30 ans et les festivités
commenceront demain et qui viendra
compléter l'offre déjà présente sur
espace saint quentin en répondant à une
cible de clientèle en recherche
justement de loisirs l'arrivée des furet
du nord va-t-elle être suivie d'autres
annonces dans les prochaines semaines ou
dans les prochains mois bien évidemment
on va pas s'arrêter là bien au contraire
donc dans le sens je peux vous annoncer
sur courant 2010 8 courant deuxième
jeunesse 2018 par exemple sur le thème
du loisir l'arrivée d'alou et qui est
une enseigne de loisirs créée par deux
lyonnais avec un seul une seule enseigne
sur lyon est donc le second arrivera en
région parisienne et plus précisément
sur skywest donc on aura le plaisir de
les accueillir et qui proposera de la
simulation de voitures de formule 1 /
verra par exemple donc l'arrivée des
frais du nord marque un tournant
vraiment dans le centre commercial sqy
ouest
on se recentre plutôt sur la culture et
les loisirs c'est une vraie volonté de
la part à des clients alors c'est une
vraie demande on a la chance de pouvoir
établir régulièrement des études
clientèle qui nous ont permis
effectivement devenir affiner notre
notre projet et il y avait une vraie
attente sur ce domaine justement sur le
sur le loisir
alors l'arrivée des secours en 2010 il
sera complété par d'autres
d'autres enseignes dans la restauration
par exemple nous accueillerons hobby
chef qui est une enseigne de beagle
fraîche burritos une enseigne mexicaine
vraiment des enseignes qui apporte
quelque chose de nouveau et comme je
disais tout à l'heure qui vient au
compléter une offre plus standards qu'on
retrouve sur le centre commercial espace
saint quentin
vous avez fait des études pour recentrer
skywest vers le loisir
nous réalisons déjà des études tous les
deux ans où nous questionnons
nos nos clients sur leurs points de
satisfaction leurs attentes de ces de
ces études nous en ressortons des
conclusions et ses conclusions nous
permettre justement de construire des
projets donc alors c'est pour ça que ça
prend plus beaucoup de temps plus de
plusieurs mois peut voir plusieurs
années parce qu'en plus des négociations
effectivement maintenant cette intimité
avec nos clients de manière à répondre à
leurs attentes
merci beaucoup mohamed est bon démarrage
demain pour les férus du nord je le
rappelle c'est demain mercredi à skywest
que les furet du nord ouvrent leurs
portes
merci à vous amical et aussi à patrick
jacques de dixmude au cadrage vous le
rappeler l'enseigne culturelle des furet
du nord qui ouvrira donc demain à
skywest après plusieurs mois de travaux
ce chantier lui n'a pas commencé mais on
sait désormais à quoi ressemblera l
église saint joseph le bienveillant à
voisins le bretonneux les architectes
ont présenté jeudi dernier à la version
définitive de l'édifice religieux devant
les fidèles situé dans la future zac de
la remise l'église pourra accueillir 800
personnes et affichera et des lignes
pour le moins futuriste nickel et demi
d'euros et au rayon ce dans trois ans
les paroissiennes et les paroissiens de
montigné voisins le bretonneux pourront
se retrouver dans ce lieu plus de 250
personnes avaient fait le déplacement
pour découvrir les esquisses définitive
d'un projet qui remonte à plus de dix
ans un édifice et qui se voit et qui
à la fois montre la prière l'accueil des
personnes qui est qui qui sont
chrétiennes ou qui ne sont pas
chrétienne anne édifices ou des
chrétiens prient et et se réunissent le
dimanche pour prier en semaine un projet
de 7,5 millions d'euros financés par le
diocèse de versailles et qui se voulait
participatif les gens ont été associés à
la définition du cahier des charges au
choix du nom à la discussion sur les
premières esquisses
donc les gens se prennent au jeu on peut
dire et ont envie que cette église soit
la maison de tous et qu'ils aient tous
pu participer à sa conception
une démarche qui a visiblement séduit
les intéressés qui approuve ce projet et
ses lignes modernes
je pense qu'aujourd'hui à l'église ne
doit être tournée vers vers demain
et cette église est bien le reflet de à
la fois de la tradition l'église et en
même temps d'une église qui est tourné
vers l'avenir
ce qui me plaît c'est l'aspect
maternelle rond et les deux tantes qui
se rencontrent ça je trouve ça
extraordinaire
l'heure est désormais à la réflexion sur
la décoration intérieure les travaux eux
devraient commencer début 2019 pour une
ouverture prévue en 2020 mission mieux
manger les dix jours de l' équilibre
alimentaire se déroule en ce moment à
trappes c'est jusqu'à vendredi
atelier cuisine sorties et dépistage
gratuit du diabète sont au menu de cet
événement pour en parler avec moi
maureen auger bonsoir quand ça vous êtes
la directrice adjointe de la maison des
parents de trappes qui organise
l'événement alors l'animation a débuté
les animations ont débuté le 11 octobre
dernier pendant la semaine du goût qui
regroupe des milliers d'initiatives en
matière d'alimentation et ce n'est pas
la première fois que tu rappes que la
maison des parents organisent un
événement autour de l'alimentation c'est
devenu une habitude chaque année c'est
ça en fait à la maison des parents
pilote ce projet qui est un projet
municipal et c'est grâce à une
subvention de la rs qu'on peut le mener
à bien le but c'est de faire rayonner
cette action sur l'ensemble des services
de la ville aussi bien de services de
jeunesse de petite enfance de l'enfance
donc sur les établissements scolaires
également
oui parce que ça va se dérouler sur
plusieurs lieux d'exactement ça se
déroule sur plusieurs lieux de la ville
y a un effet un temps fort qui se
déroule actuellement sur dix jours au
centre ou dans les centres
socioculturels avec des ateliers cuisine
comme vous l'avez dit avec dépistage de
diabète mais le but c'est vraiment de
faire rayonner sa pour sensibiliser
l'ensemble de la population ce soit des
jeunes des moins jeunes quand on s'est
nourri logé que oui l'obésité touche en
france 15% de la population et qui parmi
cette population a beaucoup de plus en
plus de jeunes qui sont touchés par
l'obésité que les prévisions aussi de
l'organiser l'organisation mondiale de
la santé ne sont pas bonnes en la
matière on imagine aussi à la toute
l'importance de d'informer d'organiser
cet événement sur l'alimentation
oui et en plus sur trappe
particulièrement un contexte quand même
territoriale qui est assez assez
défavorisant on va dire pour cette
mesure d'obésité dans la mesure où on a
presque 27% de la population qui vit en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté donc
forcément qu'il y en a forcément les
moyens de manger correctement donc avec
ce moyen de pauvreté obésité sont
parfois lieu exactement et donc du coup
le but c'est de mettre à disposition des
ateliers tels que les ateliers de
cuisine avec une diététicienne pour
apprendre le bien manger sur des coûts
de revient très très très très très très
très accessible et de voilà d'avoir eu
un impact sur sur l'ensemble d'une
famille en particulier et donc de
plusieurs et donc nous notre action se
déroulera sur dix jours et non la
prolonge au sein de la maison des
parents sur un atelier pendant une
semaine la première semaine des vacances
de la toussaint avec avec donc des
ateliers parents enfin notre cible c'est
les 11 15 ans quand ces jeunes c'est
famille ses parents nous viennent soit
de manière spontanée en entendant parler
de ce programme la soignent sont
orientés par des médecins généralistes
qui sont de la ville et qui sont
inscrits aurait peur ou alors par les
infirmières scolaires leur hip hop juste
pourquoi
c'est un réseau de prévention de
l'obésité pédiatrique très bien donc
donc voilà est donc le but c'est
vraiment de
voilà deux d'avoir une action de
prévention et de ne pas le faire seul
dans notre coin mais de le faire
rayonner avec des partenaires de la
ville donc les infirmières scolaires
notamment les médecins et médecins
généralistes mais aussi le centre de
santé municipal
on rappelle aussi bas ce qu'est la
structure de la maison des parents qui
organise je le rappelle cet événement
c'est un véritable lieu de relais pour
les parents afin de les informer sur
l'éducation de leurs enfants
ouais ouais non ces deux définitions
retenues
c'est un lieu ressource je dirais
d'abord à ce que relève bien sûr on fait
le relais parce qu'on n'est pas là pour
faire du suivi concerne ce cri pas du
tout dans une concurrence que ce soit
avec le conseil départemental où la pmi
tout ça le but c'est vraiment de
recevoir les familles de travailler sur
le lien de la parentalité le lien
parents afin de leur donner des clés des
billes mais que bien sûr si une
situation qui relève bas pas de notre
compétence on est là effectivement pour
passer le relais et donc et donc
d'orienter au mieux nos familles oui non
pardon des animations vous avez déjà un
peu dit des choses là dessus il ya des
ateliers cuisine qui sont organisés donc
en ce moment il y en a un je dis
notamment au centre socioculturel des
merisiers de 9h à 12h c'est le bio à
tout prix c'est une une question un
autre atelier aussi c'est l'alimentation
face au diabète vendredi de 13h à 15h30
également au centre socioculturel des
merisiers la seo l idée donner des
solutions aussi clé en main on parle on
exactement en fait c'est sur des petits
groupes on accueille dix douze personnes
vraiment maximum
il ya notre j'étais titienne qui vient
donc c'est un eric renard qu avec
laquelle on a l'habitude de travailler
qui vient et qui donne oui des débits
des recettes des choses très simples à
faire très rapidement parce que ben
voilà parce que quand on est maman quand
on n'est pas pas et qu'on travaille le
saint louvent le frigo il faut vite
trouver quelque chose
donc oui le but c'est ça c'est de donner
des outils pour s'organiser
et puis pour bien manger avec toute la
famille des enfants je voulais aussi
aborder avec vous enfin le dépistage
gratuit du diabète
il y en a plusieurs il y en a eu trois
tout au long de cet événement il y en
aura un dernier donc vendredi de 13h30 à
15h30 au centre socioculturel luxure ou
attrape
pourquoi mettre en place aussi voilà ces
dépistages c'est fort c'est parfois
difficile y accéder de alors je pense
que oui c'est pas on n'en communique on
communique beaucoup dessus mais on ne
sait pas forcément comment d'une part on
dépiste alors que c'est plutôt rapide
puisque c'est un c'est un test de
glycémie le souci c'est que il va pas
forcément être probants et que là on va
plus détecté un facteur de risque de
développer cette maladie là et on va les
orienter après vers le centre de santé
municipal pour poursuivre le dépistage
voila mail accès libre
voilà on peut y aller il ya le petit
déjeuner qui sera offert en plus sur
place donc allez-y
merci morhino gels d'avoirs et
interdictions rappel vous êtes la
directrice adjointe de la maison à des
parents de trappes
elle organise jusqu'à vendredi à les dix
jours de l' équilibre alimentaire c'est
jusqu'à vendredi je viens de le dire et
le programme complet est à retrouver sur
le site internet de la ville de trappes
www.kraton.com faire vous en avez
désormais l'habitude comme chaque mardi
le portrait de la rédaction sur une
personnalité des yvelines ce soir
direction le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour faire la
connaissance d'alexandra bonetti la
sportive est à 25 ans l'une des plus
grande golfeuse française de sa
génération
michael et demi d'euros la rencontre et
sur les greens alexandra bonetti et
joueuses professionnelles sur le circuit
européen mais avant d'en faire son
métier le golf est avant tout une
passion pour cette parisienne de 25 ans
la sportive à taper ses premières balles
à l'âge de 7 ans au golf national de
saint quentin en yvelines après avoir vu
ses parents joués décidé à s'améliorer
elle a ensuite pris des cours dans la
structure sous l'impulsion de sa famille
on a dû commencer à prendre des leçons
vers l'âge de 10 ans il avait une super
école de golf ici
vraiment vraiment super donc j'y suis
resté jusqu'à mes 17 ans et tous les
week-ends il m'amenait le mercredi après
midi il m'amenait après l'école
ils ont joué ils ont tout fait pour maj
+ réussir dans ce que j'aime cette
passion à développer son esprit de
compétition 2007 à saint quentin divina
golfeuses décroche à 15 ans la médaille
de bronze du championnat d'europe dames
en étant invité du tournoi à un moment
clé dans sa jeune carrière presque
impensable clip de je me suis dit
vraiment
suite à cette performance alexandra
bonetti intègre l'équipe de france
termine 3e des championnats du monde
amateurs en argentine en 2010 et rafle
l'or au championnat d'europe dames en
après son bac elle joue dans une
université au texas entre 2011 et 2015
et sillonne les greens américain pour
continuer à engranger les succès sur le
circuit la joueuse s'entraîne de façon
intense six jours sur sept
donc il ya cinq séances de sport par
semaine que je fais soit le matin avant
de venir au gal soit dans la soirée et
ensuite c'est un
un équilibre entre le practice le petit
jeu donc petit shipping et le parcours
donc ça prend pas mal de temps à
l'entraînement nécessaire pour réaliser
une quinzaine de tournois par an quatre
coins du monde et surtout pour
perfectionner son point fort le jeu
court pour cela alexandra a mis en place
une technique
je vais prendre beaucoup de recul
derrière la bad pour regarder une
première fois la ligne surtout les
gauches droites
puis je vais aller de l'autre côté là je
vais aller un peu moins loin pour
surtout centrée sur la fin du pote et
les mouvements à près du trou et ensuite
je vais repasser par le côté le plus bas
cette technique sur le jeu court lui
permettra peut-être de réussir à
intégrer le circuit américain dame à
l'horizon 2019
l'un de ses plus grands rêves de golf us
à bientôt
le week-end dernier pompiers policiers
gendarmes et associatifs étaient réunis
à voisins le bretonneux pour
sensibiliser à la sécurité routière
nombreuses animations proposées comme la
voiture tonneau ou encore le simulateur
de conduite nicolas landry et les arrêts
ch
[Musique]
non ce n'est pas la nouvelle attraction
de la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux
mais plutôt une animation de prévention
routière souad et sa fille yasmine pour
participer à ces exercices
le but de cette voiture tonneau c'est
bien mettre la ceinture on va vous
expliquer certaines règles c'est des
automatismes ça prend quelques secondes
plusieurs stands de sensibilisation ont
été installés dans la cour de l'espace
culturel decauville afin que chacun
puisse mieux appréhender les dangers à
travers des masques les participants
vont pouvoir ressentir les symptômes de
l'alcool ou du cannabis et ainsi tester
leurs capacités physiques
en fait je voyais rien je voyais que le
haut et je voyais comme une loupe et le
beh devait baisser la tête pour pouvoir
voir c'est pour pouvoir le faire
comprendre aux personnes quittaient ce
alors évidemment d'abord les adultes et
on peut le faire aussi à certains
enfants comprendre le comportement qu'on
peut avoir face à ce type de de
consommation et par rapport à la le
comportement du cerveau par rapport à ce
type de message la volonté du
département et de réduire la mortalité
sur la route qui a la mienne et 2017 et
en os sur le territoire en cause
notamment l'alcool la fatigue et la
vitesse
ces images avant de se quitter cyril
hanouna l'animateur cyril hanouna a
rendu visite à l'association et médias
handicap il était la guest star de la
journée de l'espérance dimanche au
centre sportif pierre de coubertin à
montigny le bretonneux
un événement pour changer les regards
sur le handicap des défis étaient
d'ailleurs proposé cyril hanouna on a
relevé trois celui du goût du basket
fauteuil est un défi les yeux bandés
créée en 2004 médias handicap promeut
une autre image des personnes
handicapées plus d'informations sur la
page facebook de l'association
c'est la fin de ce set 8 journal
reportages et replay a consultés sur
notre site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 excellente soirée à tous
[Musique]